Ahorita yo tengo una declaración muy religiosa.
En el año treinta y nueve, en mi ciudad, era un hombre pobre.
Su mujer murió, se casó segunda vez, y él alquiló árboles en Polonia, en Alemania,
donde crecen frutas, peras, manzanas, y muchas cosas.
Y él alquilaba de campesinos, por ejemplo, en abril ya alquilaba, y junio, julio, ya
alquilaba, vendía, y asimile esa matanía el año.
Siempre cada año faltaba era para pagar vino, présteme tanto, no podía ser mucho, no puedo,
y siempre me devolvió.
En el año treinta y nueve vino él, présteme, cuánto, no me acuerdo, no podía ser.
¿Qué pasó?
Él en el año treinta y nueve alquiló una hacienda, muchos árboles, y allá de la primera
hierba en 1918 se quedó un pozo, creció hierba, y él caminaba a la noche viendo y
cayó allá en ese pozo.
Sacaron a él y él murió.
Todo eso pasó en el año treinta y nueve.
El año treinta y nueve de septiembre, el otro día, no, perdón, el otro día de septiembre,
era en mayo, que se pasó en abril, en mayo.
El otro día me estaba faltando, yo había comido a mi mamá, yo tenía un remoto y mi
mamá tenía otro remoto, me dieron un subeño, me dice así, perdóname.
Que yo te deba beber.
Entonces yo me despierto y me río, ya yo no me acordaba, entonces mi mamá estaba yendo
con yo, me río, ella pasé para el miradorio, dice, ¿por qué se ríes?
Y digo así, sí, códelo, no, códelo, vino que yo, perdóneme, que yo no me acuerdo
de cuánto tiempo estoy, ya no me acuerdo de eso, ya, quédese, vino, y me estaba viendo.
Bien, otra vez, no se ríe, yo quiero, que mañana es sábado, otra fiesta, que tú cantes
esa cacefatora, que tú, para el pueblo, que tú me perdones, que me pasó un frío.
Yo hizo eso.
Cuando nosotros entramos en crematorio y nos olvidamos, ¿cuál era el motivo que dijeron
que se juntan hombres y mujeres juntos?
Era el motivo esto.
¿Sabe usted quién llevaba a todos los judíos para el crematorio a quemar?
Los judíos, obligaron a quien trabajara.
¿Usted me entiende?
No me entiende.
Los judíos llevaron a los judíos de adentro, en crematorio, en el sereno, para el crematorio,
no con su voluntad, por obligación.
¿Qué pasó?
Se hizo en una pieza de efecto, que no podía hacer su vuelta.
Entonces, pasaron las ocho, y estoy llegando a mi...
¿El domingo de mañana?
No, señor, quédese sentado, señor.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
Ya me siento en la tierra de esta forma, y con mis manos así, y con Dios mío.
¿Qué es este mundo que es?
¿Qué voy a pasar en el hogar?
¿Qué yo perdono?
¿Para esto yo voy a vivir tanto tiempo con mi abuelo y mi hija?
¿Cuánto mi abuelo voy a vivir?
Yo no sé, pero yo me llamo por mi abuelo.
Como hoy, en miércoles de Dios,
como declaro la verdad,
se abre la portica, y entra el jefe del crematorio.
¿Holzame?
Y dice,
¡Reyes, ¿qué haces aquí?
Yo contesto
por mi falsa obra que he hecho,
por mi trabajo que siempre he cumplido con usted.
Entra y decide.
¿Qué yo he perdonado?
Más o menos, el cárculo es mío.
El domingo de mañana
era más o menos como 40.000 pesos.
El cárculo.
Ni paro allá.
Entonces,
aquí, full, exceso, gendarmería,
y toda la gente allá al frente,
yo estoy aquí.
Entonces, todo el mundo dice,
¡Reyes, diga que yo soy su mujer,
que yo soy su hermano, que yo soy su papá!
¿Qué estoy pensando yo?
Háganme con el dedo,
mi señora que venga.
Ella estaba, y eso.
Y yo hice con el dedo.
Ella empezó a trabajar, y caminaba.
Y un momento,
un exceso como él,
altos, hermanos, matriadores,
y se pegaba con la cabeza,
yo tenía tanta fuerza,
y a toda dios, brincó,
agarró un matriador con un busto,
en orden,
para que mi mujer venga conmigo.
Cuando yo nombró, el jefe dijo,
¡Ólzama, ya voy!
Y dijo, mira, mira.
¿Usted entiende eso?
¿Hay contrastación?
¿Hay fuerza de Dios?
¿Por qué es que estoy escogido esto?
¿Qué puedo explicar hoy?
No puede contestar.
¿Hoy he hecho algo malo?
Hoy he hecho algo bueno.
Tampoco lo puede contestar.
Yo soy castigado,
como dijo este señor.
¿En qué forma yo estoy castigado?
Abram Ovine,
el padre de los otros,
era un hijo de Teras.
Y en ese tiempo de Abram,
existía que cada cura ocupaba
muchos terrenos en el mundo.
El padre de él,
hizo todos los ejercicios de Dios.
Entonces Abram,
un Dios de Yesos no parecía,
agarró un palo
y entró en el jardín de su padre
y le rompió todos los ejercicios de Yesos.
El padre de él se llamaba Teras.
Llamaba a todos sus menores.
Y el padre de Abram,
se llamaba Teras.
Llamaban a todos sus ministros.
¿Qué tenemos acerca del hijo
que no respeta a su padre?
Y el dice que su padre no cree en Dios.
Salud, justicia,
y hay que amar a él.
Señorizar,
y quieren un horno.
Dice Talmud,
y me quieren este horno.
que era ya no le había calor,
no se quemó,
y se iba pasando en un jardín.
Yo cuando estudiaba eso Talmud,
yo dije al Señor,
eso es imposible.
Meter a una persona en un sanatorio,
y sale con vida.